er ist dieses düstere kapitel noch immer
nicht aufgearbeitet
mai 1945 die rote armee ist das banner
der sieger auf dem reichstag
es ist das ende nazideutschlands hitler
und die ms elite haben sich bereits das
leben genommen
zwei stunden nördlich von berlin in
einer provinzstadt vorpommerns trägt
sich zu genau dieser zeit einer der
größten tragödien der letzten kriegstage
zu der massenselbstmord von dem was die
nationalsozialisten gemacht entweder
haben wir alles oder wir haben nichts
entweder werden wir die welt herrscher
oder deutschland geht komplett zugrunde
und das haben die leute verinnerlicht
eine selbstmordwelle erfasste
deutschland 1945 vor allem östlich der
elbe
der historiker florian huber
recherchierte die hintergründe in termin
löschten sich ganze familien aus eltern
wissen ihre kinder mit in den tod
kind versprich mir dass du dich
erschießt so heißt das buch über das
lange tabuisierte thema heute sind die
demminer selbst interessiert an der
aufarbeitung die sterbebücher belegen
jeder fünfzehnte brachte sich damals um
ein massen suizid sehr schnell klar wenn
man diese bücher in die hand nimmt und
anfängt zu blättern
dass es das was geschehen ist was
beispielloses termin wird gegen
kriegsende zur falle
tausende ost flüchtlinge standen hier
weil die deutsche wehrmacht die brücken
nach westen gesprengt hat von osten her
die rote armee
angst geht um vor der vergeltung der
sieger denn deutschland hatte zuvor
einen vernichtungskrieg gegen die
russische bevölkerung geführt an die
ausmaße der panik vor der willkür der
roten armee erinnert sich auch karl
schlosser
mir liegt die leichen gesehen die in den
bäumen blühenden apfelbäumen oder die
mmm fluss aufgedunsen schwammen das
haben wir schon als kinder dann sehr
schnell begriffen was da passiert ist
und auch uns hätte passieren können
karl schlosser war damals ziehen auch
seine mutter versuchte ihm seinen bruder
und sich selbst umzubringen
doch der großvater ging dazwischen
scharenweise gingen damals vor allem
frauen mit ihren kindern in den tod
es ist auch ihre geschichte
lilo schlösser karl schlösser ehefrau
sie schaut bilder ihrer mutter und ihres
kleinen bruders an beide tot
lilo schlösser war vier jahre alt als
russische soldaten das haus stürmten in
dem sie damals lebte ihre großcousine
wurde vergewaltigt so oft und so brutal
dass sie an ihren verletzungen starb
die frauen haben dann
panik gekriegt meine mutter wusste
sowieso siehst die nächste und dann
wurde die rasierklinge angesetzt und
gestorben sind daran an diesem pulsader
schnitt meine mutter mein kleiner bruder
und der sohn der cousine dienen auch
gestorben ist
lilo schlösser wurde in ihrem blut
gefunden
gerade noch rechtzeitig sie überlebte
als einziges kind der familie termin
kennt viele schauplätze der verzweiflung
einen weiteren grund für den selbstmord
zog sieht huber in zwölf jahren
nazi-diktatur moralische lehre trümmer
in den köpfen
die deutschen sehen keine zukunft mehr
und nehmen sie auch ihren kindern
die nazis hatten es vorgemacht
propagandaminister joseph goebbels und
seine frau vergifteten ihrer sechs
kinder in leipzig brachte sich ns
stadtkämmerer kulisse mitsamt familie um
1000 jahre deutsches reich oder
untergang die selbstzerstörerische logik
des ns systems erfasste selbst die
kleinen leute auch als der krieg schon
vorbei war
natürlich ist selbstmorden extreme
reaktion auf diesem sinn verlust und auf
dieses vakuum und auf dieses nichts für
den mann jetzt plötzlich stand aber es
ist trotzdem erstens eine massenaktion
gewesen und zweitens war eben die
kehrseite dieser reaktion also die leute
die sich jetzt nicht umgebracht haben
das war die grosse mehrheit natürlich in
deutschland die sind ja dann wie wir
wissen in schweigen verfallen ja in die
wettringer
lange wollte niemand die geschichte des
untergangs dieser kleinen leute erzählen
florian huber hat es nun getan
ein blick in die zerstörten seelen der
stunde null